- [Man] T-minus 10, nine, eight, seven,
six, five, four, three.
- There's a border that all of us share.
And it keeps getting closer and closer.
It's right above our heads.
But it's not a border
between two countries,
it's actually a boundary to a place
that used to be accessible
to just a few of us,
but now more and more of
us can cross this boundary.
- [Reporter] What's been dubbed
the billionaire space race.
- And as that happens,
we humans risk messing it up.
We risk sealing this border completely
so no person or object can escape earth.
I want to show you how this might happen
and what we can do to avoid it.
- [Woman] Long-term simulations
show an exponential growth
in the number of objects in space.
- This is low earth orbit.
It's a zone about a thousand
kilometers above earth.
This is a place where earth's gravity
can kind of pull you down,
but just enough to put you
into a perpetual free fall
that we call an orbit.
Satellites we send into space
can orbit earth as far out
as tens of thousands of kilometers,
but it is in this low earth orbit
where a majority of
earth's satellites reside.
The satellites here give
us images like these
from telescopes like this.
They also allow us to
anticipate hurricanes,
and observe trends like these.
These satellites gave
us the satellite phone.
- Who has the satellite phone?
- They connect people to the internet,
and they help us map the world,
which is something I am very grateful for.
The satellites in low earth
orbit are incredibly important.
Okay so how many satellites are up there?
Like 50 or maybe 100?
Let's see, how many, I'm Googling
on my phone, let's check.
6,000?
Whoa, okay.
So there's 6,000 satellites
floating around the earth.
Turns out that half of those are dead.
They used to be satellites,
now they're just hunks of metal
the size of a small school bus
spinning around our planet.
Of the 3,000 or so working satellites,
some are military, some are government,
but more than half of them are commercial.
Sorry, did that land?
Let me just say it again.
Half of the satellites are commercial,
they're from private companies.
Let me explain why that's a big deal.
For most of the time that
we've been traveling to space,
space has been a government thing.
It was Russia that put
up the first satellite
into low earth orbit in the '50s.
It was the Cold War so the U.S.
was like we can do that too,
and we're gonna do it better,
so they created NASA, and focused
on getting as many
satellites as they could
up into space.
- We need science,
this is for the American people,
the most critical problem of all.
- A bunch of these launches
just sort of blew up
because they were really terribly made,
but eventually they got
satellites into space.
They had something to prove.
Space was a political thing at the time.
- President Eisenhower
reassures the nation
that Russia's success
with the first satellite
does not indicate a serious lag
in American rocket research.
- And the U.S. poured tons of
money into making this happen,
and they did.
- Our satellite is definitely on orbit.
- So at this point space
was a government thing,
but boy has that changed.
(upbeat music)
In recent years there
has been an explosion
of satellites being put into space
that are not from the
government or military,
but from private businesses,
to the point where today in 2021
there are over 100 private companies
that are building vehicles to
take more stuff into space.
This is a space economy, it's a big deal.
And because of that, more and more stuff
is going into space.
This year, 2021, we've already launched
1100 objects into space.
That's the same total as
we did in all of 2020,
and nearly 10% of what we've
ever sent up into space.
The numbers are going up
faster and faster and faster
every single year.
But there's a problem,
potentially a huge problem
with all of this stuff
going up into space,
and that problem is that space,
at least low earth orbit,
this area right around
our earth is limited.
Let me explain what I mean here.
You have all of these objects
floating around our earth.
More and more every year.
So what happens if two of these satellites
by chance collide?
So what?
Satellites collide and maybe
some rich company loses
some money, who cares?
No, no no no no no, no no no no.
Reminder that these objects
are flying around earth
at 28,000 kilometers an hour,
that's eight kilometers a second.
That's one second, eight kilometers.
They go around earth 12 times per day.
And at that speed, things
get a little bit crazy.
A few years ago, a fleck of debris,
like a little piece of dust
that was one millimeter in diameter,
like the tip of a sharp
pencil, a tiny fleck,
was floating through low
earth orbit at this speed,
and it hit a satellite's solar panels.
And this tiny fleck of dust
left a giant gash in the panels.
It was one millimeter in diameter.
In 2009, a collision between
a defunct Russian space craft
and an operational commercial satellite
created this exact kind of shrapnel cloud,
completely disintegrated.
More than 2,300 hunks of space junk
that are now floating around our planet
at 28,000 kilometers an hour.
This shrapnel at one point put
the Hubble Telescope at risk,
and it sort of freaked people out.
In an instant, two objects
turned into thousands of objects,
all with new paths
floating around our earth.
So the fear here is that
what if this became a chain reaction?
One collision makes more debris
which leads to another collision
which means even more
debris, and more collisions,
and suddenly low earth orbit
becomes a minefield of space junk
hurling around our
planet at deathly speeds
and launches a domino effect
that would wipe out our
space infrastructure
leaving us trapped on the surface of earth
for generations beneath a violent cloud
of speeding shrapnel.
Unable to send anything up to
space for a very long time.
This is the nightmare scenario.
It's a scenario that's
portrayed in the movie Gravity
which is a very good movie.
Quick pause to thank today's
sponsor, Policy Genius.
Policy Genius is a place
where you can compare quotes
for life insurance.
Life insurance is one of those things
that you sort of don't
think about very often,
you don't want to think about it
because it's sort of
associated with big what-ifs.
But it's one of these
things that is wise to have.
And especially while you're young,
you can lock in a really
low rate on life insurance,
I actually just went
through this whole process.
I signed up using Policy Genius,
and was able to compare quotes
from a bunch of different life insurers.
I did this all very quickly
and then got on the phone with
an expert at Policy Genius
and soon I had a life insurance policy.
So now I am insured,
I have life insurance,
and it feels actually really good.
You can save 50% or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with Policy Genius.
And you can get covered
in as little as a week.
For me it was super quick,
I didn't have to go do a
health exam or anything,
I was just able to do all the
health stuff over the phone,
and I got covered.
It was like 15 or 20 minutes of my time.
Policy Genius never
sells your information,
or anything like that
which I am a big fan of.
They're just simple, and save you money.
So head to PolicyGenius.com/JohnnyHarris,
going to that link, which
is also in my description,
helps support this channel,
but it also gets you started today
on saving money with life insurance.
All right, let's get
back to space borders.
Eventually of course, over the years,
this debris would slowly
fall into the atmosphere,
it would lose altitude,
and it would burn up in our atmosphere.
But that would be generations
of a world without satellites.
A world that is sealed from space.
Okay okay listen listen,
this is not gonna happen anytime soon,
by all counts we are safe
from the chain reaction,
the probabilities are very low.
It isn't likely right now.
There's a lot of space up there.
- [Man] Space, the final frontier.
- But we are sending up
thousands of satellites per year now.
This may not be an issue now,
it certainly will be soon.
So what do you do with this?
We're in the midst of this new space race,
just like the one between the Soviets
and the U.S. in the '50s
but this time it's not governments,
it's like this guy,
and a bunch of guys just like him.
And they're the ones
who are racing to space,
and they don't really care about
the potential scenario
of a chain reaction.
Do you know why?
Because they have investors to please,
and a world to show that they can
privatize space the fastest.
(laughing)
So let's talk about the U.S.
government really quick.
Of the 3,000 working satellites,
about 2,000 of them are American.
They come from American companies
or the American government.
So you would expect the American
space government agency,
NASA, to be the responsible steward
of low earth orbit,
and make sure that these
private space companies
are at least following some traffic rules
when they send them up into space
so that they don't collide.
Alas, no one, including NASA,
wants to be the one to slow
down the new space race.
Instead they are focusing on quote,
accelerating a thriving commercial economy
in low earth orbit.
The U.S. government is sort of doing
what it did in the '50s,
we've got a get an edge
on this new space thing
and let's focus on just getting
as much stuff up as we can.
So NASA is helping to fund
these private space companies
who are sending up so many satellites
and objects into space.
Like SpaceX, Elon Musk's company
is sending up 60 satellites a month.
60 satellites just being
thrust into space every month,
and he's asked for a lot more.
He wants to get 42,000 up there.
That's what he's asking for,
that's what he's asking for approval for,
42,000, just 42,000.
So far he's gotten approval for 12,000.
Amazon is now getting into the space game.
They've been approved
to send up over 3,000.
We're not slowing down.
So clearly the race is on,
and no one's thinking
too hard about traffic.
- You're blaming me for the traffic?
- Should I?
- So how do we avoid
filling up low earth orbit?
And avoid the collisions
that could potentially cause
a devastating chain reaction.
These companies are taking some protocol,
like SpaceX will send up these satellites
in like a caravan,
like a line of satellites
which looks really trippy by the way.
I was out stargazing for
my galaxy video last year
and I looked up and I saw
this like perfect line
of blinking dots in the sky
and I was like what is happening?
I was sure that I was seeing a UFO,
like this is it.
Like I've had my encounter
with extra terrestrials.
It was like an existential moment for me,
I was like what is happening?
20 minutes later I looked it up
and learned about the
caravans that SpaceX does.
They do this so that all of the satellites
are in the same path
so that they have way less
likelihood of colliding
because they're not just on random paths
they're like all together.
So yeah these private companies
are taking some precautions,
but as we all know,
you can't rely on private companies
to regulate themselves
for the good of everyone.
Like, are we really gonna be like
you guys regulate yourself
and we'll all be safe and
everyone will be good, no.
That's not how it works.
What we need is mutually agreed upon laws
on how stuff can be launched
into low earth orbit
so that we actually have some
traffic management in space.
There are no rules of the road in space,
no formal agreements on
how traffic should behave
in low earth orbit.
In other words, this is the wild west.
Wait, isn't there like space law?
Like treaties?
Like the outer space
treaty, the moon treaty,
the International Space Station,
yeah but none of these
things talk about traffic.
All these countries have
signed these treaties
that just say space is for everybody,
no one can conquer space, no Star Wars.
- That isn't very reassuring.
- Closest any treaty gets to addressing
the space traffic thing,
says that quote, states shall be liable
for damage caused by their space objects.
In other words, if you send an object up,
and your country damages an
object from another country,
your country has to take
responsibility in some form.
But wait, does that actually happen?
Remember that defunct Russian space craft
that collided with the
commercial satellite in 2009?
Who took responsibility?
And wait, was it the Russian satellite
that hit the commercial one,
or was it the commercial one
that hit the Russian one?
Like how do you dole out responsibility
and blame when you're talking about
two satellites just floating through space
who happen to run into each other.
So in the end, the responsibility
landed squarely on the
shoulders of, nobody.
- How did we get into this mess?
- Decision makers couldn't even agree
on who was responsible
for launching the commercial
satellite in the first place
because multiple countries were
involved with launching it,
and they hadn't registered it with the UN
like they promised they would
back in some treaty in 1972.
I mean it's a total mess.
There is no order or regulation
or clarity in space law,
which right now is fine,
but soon it won't be.
So here we are with no traffic rules,
no history of holding anyone accountable
for unintentional space collisions,
and we're about to send up
tens of thousands more satellites.
What we need is productive cooperation,
like humans have been able to do
in so many aspects of our
global international system.
The International Space
Station is a great example.
It has functioned
as a multi-national
collaborative project in space.
Unfortunately what I've learned
is that when there's
competition among countries,
a lot of these cooperative efforts
sort of go out the window.
There is growing tension
between two super powers,
China and the U.S.
And China is in the middle of constructing
their own space station
for low earth orbit.
India is preparing to
send their own as well.
This is competition, not cooperation.
Our existing space law,
which was all sort of drafted
in the '60s and the '70s
never anticipated private companies
sending up thousands of satellites.
And it didn't anticipate
China and India and the U.S.
Competing for space power.
Our desire to explore space
is not just about showing how powerful
and innovative we are.
So much technology has come
from our space exploration.
From solar cells to cochlear implants,
to firefighting technology.
The development of the micro chip
which was majorly accelerated by NASA,
and now microchips drive our entire world.
The pursuit of reaching out into space
has consistently driven
meaningful innovation.
So this is important,
we should absolutely protect the future
of this really wonderful
thing that humans have done.
We've escaped our atmosphere,
we've escaped gravity,
and we've learned so much in the process.
So, there are a lot of objects in space,
they're floating around,
and there is a body of treaties and law
that is way outdated.
My hope is that as we send
these thousands and thousands
of satellites into space,
we consider the
implications of what happens
if we get too hasty,
send too much stuff up
and things start to run into each other.
It's not worth the risk in my mind.
If we don't look ahead,
we could turn space from a border
that we can all cross together,
and learn together as human beings,
into a border that is impenetrable,
that's dangerous, that keeps us trapped
here on this warming planet,
unable to continue to explore
the world of outer space.
(soft music)